we told you last night about a shocking
report that found laws legalizing
marijuana have not driven organized
crime out of the pot trade just the
opposite they've created a huge gold
rush for foreign drug cartels our guest
Mason Verte of the Marijuana Policy
Project disagreed when states like
Colorado and Washington and California
what we're seeing is that the demand
amongst the population in those states
is being met by a new legal market where
the product is being controlled it's
being grown and sold by licensed
businesses that statement really irks
Sheriff Bill elder of El Paso County in
Colorado and he joins us now from Denver
sheriff you're on the frontlines you see
the results of pot legalization I have
been a staunch critic of this move to
legalize drugs for years now you see the
money in it it is huge money for
corporations lobbyists are swarming all
over Washington I want to play for you
what Chuck Schumer said about this let's
watch I studied the issue and we've now
had some evidence state of Washington
other states where it has done lots of
good and no harm Justice Brandeis said
let the states be laboratories now we've
had a few states we've had a few
laboratories the experiments been a
success
let's nationalize it yeah he doesn't
want the states to be laboratories of
pro-life legislation however Sheriff
well you know it has been a grand
experiment hasn't it we have we have
taken Colorado and we've opened the
floodgates and and now we've got black
market marijuana everywhere and what was
said yesterday that oh well the only
reason this is happening sheriff Felder
is because all the other states still
have a need for the pot you can't buy it
and all the other states where it's not
legal
and once it's legalized nationally then
the cartels will move out do you buy
that argument not at all not at all the
cartels have infiltrated Colorado right
and left right now we're tracking over
600 grows you know Paso County alone
another 150 to 200 in Puebla
County that are all cartel control
black-market marijuana and that
marijuana is being packaged and sold all
over the East Coast
at two to two and a half times its value
in Colorado this is ridiculous
they just say because you know once all
these other states legalize it
you know they won't have the it's just
it's driven by the desire by the market
the market demands that pot be sent all
over the country and every all these
other states need to get with it I do
want to show our viewers statistics that
they might not see anywhere else here's
the change in crime from 2013 to 2016
during the legalization period in
Colorado Colorado was up five percent
nationally it was down 9% violent crime
same period Colorado up 12.5% and
nationally up 5% corresponding to the
periods of legalization are you is that
does that comport with your own
experience with the violent crime
increase Sheriff it absolutely does I
mean we've now legalized marijuana for
medicinal uses of medicinal uses as well
as recreational uses we didn't put any
caps on it before you could grow up to
99 plants in a residential zone today
we've limited that to 12 plants in a
residential zone and every one of these
plants that are every one of these grows
that we have taken down since the first
of the year has had well over a hundred
plants since the first of the year we've
executed 64 search warrants and
recovered almost 5300 marijuana plants
that were destined for the East Coast
this is no longer an experiment so this
is Chinese Mexican and Cuban a lot of
the cartels is that right that's exactly
right and a long list of laotians in
southern Colorado this is ridiculous I
mean what a night this is about money
Sheriff this is about huge money the
tobacco industry moving into the pot
industry and apparently it's just it's
we're off to the races
we're gonna keep tabs on this and we're
gonna keep in contact with you thank you
so much